If you roll a six-sided
die and a four-sided die,
what is the probability
that neither die shows a 1?
The grid below shows all
the possible outcomes
of rolling a six-sided
die and a four-sided die.
And we're fairly familiar
with six-sided die.
Those are the cubes that we're
used to from the board games
that we've been playing
our entire lives, that
look something like that.
And your roll is
whatever is the face up.
You're probably less
familiar with four-sided die.
These are more like these
triangular pyramids.
They look something like this.
So it has 1, 2, 3, and then
the one side on the bottom.
And here your roll is
actually the face, the side,
that is facing the bottom.
And so what you have
here is a picture
of all the possible rolls.
They have the six-sided die, the
side that's facing on the top.
And then on the
triangle, this shows
what is the result of the
roll of the four-sided die.
So this actually would be
the side that's facing down.
Let's actually try to
answer their question,
because they gave us all of the
possible outcomes of rolling
a six-sided die and
a four-sided die.
So we want to know,
what is the probability
that neither dies shows a 1?
So how many total
outcomes do we have?
Let's see-- 1, 2, 3,
4 by 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
4 times 6, that makes sense.
There's six possible outcomes
for the six-sided die,
four possible outcomes
for the four-sided die.
4 times 6-- so there's 24
total possible outcomes.
And then how many
of the outcomes
meet our constraint that
neither died shows a 1?
So this one.
So anything in this
row isn't going
to meet our constraint,
because these have a 1
on the four-sided die.
And nothing in this
column is going
to meet our constraint,
because these have a 1
on the six-sided die.
But all of these,
everything left over,
these are going to
meet our constraints.
These are going to
And how many of these
outcomes are there?
Well, let's see.
There's 3 by 4-- 3 times 4.
So there's 12 possible
outcomes here.
12/24 is the probability.
You could say there's
a 12/24 probability.
But if you wanted to write
it as an equivalent fraction
that's using lower numbers, this
is the same thing as-- divide
the numerator and
denominator by 12-- 1/2.
So the probability that
neither die shows a 1 is 1/2.